what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and thor love and
thunder is right around the corner we're
a little over two weeks away but i see
it this thursday at the world premiere
so look out for my video on friday
because i'll be posting a reaction to
the movie on friday spoiler free but in
the meantime we have new footage new
posters new promotional images and some
new plot details for thor 11 thunder
revealed in some interviews some
magazine articles and of course in some
footage that we've gotten recently and
we have some of the actors who have come
out and spoken up about a few tiny
details about the movie as well like
tessa thompson and christian bale so a
lot to break down today for thor love
and thunder let's get into it and of
course if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news now first things
first apparently we have the final run
time coming from the twitter account and
insider big screen leaks i personally
know them and know they have a great
track record when it comes to these
inside scoops and they say that thor
love and thunder's final run time is 1
hour 58 minutes and 34 seconds making
this the shortest mcu movie in a very
long time but i'm not worried about this
thor ragnarok sits as one of my top 5
favorite mcu movies of all time and it's
only 2 hours and 10 minutes long and the
movie was amazing it was funny it was
also serious at the same time it had a
lot of character development it
redefined who thor was in the mcu and
for thor eleven thunder it's the same
exact people it's still chris hemsworth
taika watiti taika also helped write the
script of course as well we have jane
foster's the mighty thor coming in and
they're introducing different types of
gods to the mcu the run time doesn't
really bother me at all i have full
faith in this movie i may be a little
biased because thor is my favorite
marvel character but i do have full
trust in kevin feige taikawatiti and
chris hemsworth now some plot details
that have been revealed to us recently
about thor love and thunder through
magazine articles and through interviews
is that this movie is going to be about
thor trying to find himself it is going
to be just like thor ragnarok in a way
but this movie is also going to be sort
of a detective film which is very
interesting but it makes sense based off
of some of the footage that we saw and
some of the plot that we already know
gore the god butcher of course is the
main villain played by christian bale
and he's going to be going across the
universe killing a bunch of different
gods and what's going to happen is that
thor is going to notice that across the
universe insanely strong and powerful
gods are going to be dying in the
trailers we actually see him and korg
come across falagar the behemoth that
giant beast that is dead in the snow
this is actually a god and is actually a
friend of thor's in the comics and is an
insanely powerful god so this right here
is going to tell thor that someone is
going around killing gods and this
person is incredibly powerful and of
course gore the god godbutcher has the
all black necro sword which is basically
a sword that is a symbiote made by null
who created the symbiotes but sadly i
don't think we're gonna get any venom
connections in this film but thor and
korg realize this so they start to do
some detective work and try to hunt down
gore now when this happens i'm assuming
they're actually with the guardians of
the galaxy and when thor's with the
guardians we know that he goes through a
bunch of different phases he goes from
being the warrior that we saw at the end
of avengers end game to somebody who
wants peace and doesn't want to fight
anymore then to somebody who actually
wants to defend asgard again and we have
this really cool new scene of thor
walking through fire with the guardians
of the galaxy and if you notice this is
still bro thor he still has the beard it
looks like he still has somewhat of a
belly although he may have gotten in
shape at this point at least halfway but
this is a different thor than we've seen
be with the guardians in the trailers
the thor that we've seen with the
guardians so far is all about peace so
thor is definitely going to go through a
phase where he is fighting with the
guardians becoming a guardian of the
galaxy and becoming a ravanger because
of course we've seen him in the ravanger
close then i'm assuming something
happens on a planet with a certain type
of people maybe it's the blue species
that we've seen and thor decides that
it's time for him to put down the hammer
and stop fighting he's been fighting for
over 1500 years and kind of discover who
he truly is then from there i'm assuming
based off of what we know he finds the
dead gods decides to go back to asgard
in which asgard is getting attacked and
that's where jane foster's the mighty
thor shows up now speaking of the all
black necro sword and the symbiotes we
have seen these weird kind of almost
gooey fluid like black monsters in a few
of the trailers now and we actually have
a new scene here of gore and thor on
what looks to be some type of moon or
maybe some type of negative planet but
thor says this ends here and now and
gore looks at him and then it shows thor
and if you look behind thor we can see
some type of monsters in the background
and they look really really big and
pretty intense so i'm assuming that gore
has used the necro sword and the powers
that come with it to create these
creatures i'm kind of thinking that
since marvel studios doesn't own the
rights to use null and the symbiotes
gore the god butcher in this film is
probably going to be a combination of
gore and null so he's most likely
responsible for creating these creatures
that are attacking asgard now when thor
gets back to new asgard and helps defend
them from these creatures natalie
portman's the mighty thor shows up of
course taking arthor by big surprise
here as she's able to wield mjolnir now
he then goes to what looks to be some
type of a town hall we've seen a scene
where valkyrie is here talking to other
political figures but in this new shot
thor is there giving a speech to what
looks to be a bunch of asgardians so i'm
assuming that this is on asgard
somewhere since he's given the speech to
them and he's trying to get them to
unite and not be afraid of gore the
godbutcher and as korg and thor talk
meek is there writing everything down
that they say if you take a look at the
whiteboard that meek is writing on it is
literally word for word what korg and
thor have said and meek even drew a
little picture of mjolnir on it he drew
the old asgard where everybody came from
and some stars and some lightning also
in this new footage we see a very
interesting structure in the sky which
i'm actually assuming is olympus if you
take a look at it it's all gold like
olympus is it's floating in the sky
perhaps some place over earth but is
shielded so you can't see it i'm
assuming that it does exist in another
realm but is pretty close to earth
because in greek mythology the gods
interact with the earthly humans a lot
and if you take a look at the middle of
this structure it does look like the
place where thor jane foster korg and
the rest of the crew are walking through
in previous trailers remember olympus in
the mcu is going to kind of be like a
city in the sky which is exactly what
this looks like we can also see thor's
goats pulling a chariot with them as
they leave and we can also see the
bifrost i'm assuming that thor jane
foster and everybody else is inside this
chariot and they're using the bifrost to
go explore different parts of the
universe to try and find gore or at
least go back to new asgard we then have
another new scene of the guardians of
the galaxy and drax is yelling he's
yelling as he comes out of the water he
seems to be cutting some vines off of a
creature off of him we see nebula in the
background on the left we see rocket
raccoon in the background on the right
and we see craglin on the left as well
and it looks like he has something stuck
in his nose and on the back of his head
maybe he was attacked somehow in this
scene it does look like they're under
attack and perhaps something got him
right in the nose he does seem to be
screaming and it might be from the pain
unfortunately now i'm not assuming any
guardians are going to die in this of
course that's all going to be left for
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 but i am
really excited to see thor interact with
the guardians even more now the last
thing i want to talk about seems like
it's going to be a pretty important
scene it's of thor and he seems to be in
the same hall that we saw jane foster's
thor in the one that has the statues of
all of the cosmic entities we've only
seen jane foster in this hall before but
as we see here thor is here and in the
background is the watcher and right
behind him we know is the living
tribunal however what really caught my
eye is that to his right there seems to
be another column where there would be
another statue and we know that on the
left side are other cosmic entities as
well so this seems to be a big chamber
or hall dedicated to gods and these
cosmic entities might be considered gods
as well because it looks like some of
them are destroyed in this scene on
thor's right that column seems to be in
rubble it looks a little destroyed and
i'm assuming at one point in time gore
the god butcher went there and destroyed
the faces of some of the gods that he's
killed this might be how gore the god
butcher is kind of keeping tabs on all
of the gods every time he kills a god he
goes to this chamber and he blows up a
statue of them and this could be why
thor is really really concerned in this
shot he sees that a bunch of these
statues have been blown up and this is
going to make him realize that gore is
an even bigger threat than he thought so
thor love and thunder looks like it's
going to be a really big movie looks
like we're going to get introduced to a
bunch of different gods and possibly
even talk about the cosmic entities so
let me know your best predictions about
thor love and thunder in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest news and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching woof
me